Hi, I'm Beau Carnes with Free Code Camp. In
this course, I will teach you how to create a
full ecommerce store with WooCommerce and
WordPress. These are free tools that you
can use to create a wide variety of E commerce
websites, and I will teach you everything you
need to know step by step. This course is perfect
for beginners, there is no coding whatsoever,
and you'll be able to do everything
with a simple graphical interface.
The WooCommerce plugin makes it simple to turn
a WordPress website into a complete ecommerce
business. In this course, you will learn how
to customize your store, create products,
accept payments with credit cards and PayPal, set
taxes and shipping rates, create coupon codes,
and more. First, I'm going to show you how to
do the initial setup. This includes getting a
domain name hosting, and installing WordPress and
WooCommerce. Next, I'll show you how to install an
e commerce Store template and easily customize the
look of it so it fits with your specific brand.
After the store looks exactly how you like, I'll
show you how to add four different types of store
products. Finally, I'll show you how to set up
the payment processing automatic tax calculations,
shipping rates and coupon codes so customers can
check out on your website. Along the way, you
will also learn other tips such as customizing the
email sent to customers, adding related products,
creating store categories, and more. This course
is all you need to set up a store. But if you want
to learn more about customizing the look of your
WordPress website, you can check out my previous
WordPress course. So let's get started. First,
I'm going to show you how to get your domain
and your hosting. This is the part that you will
have to pay some money, but it is pretty cheap.
The name usually cost between 10 and $20 per
year, and hosting often cost around $5 per month,
we're going to use hosting her. There's a
lot of websites that provide website hosting,
hosting, or is provided a grant that has made this
course possible. And that's why we're going to
show you how to set things up with hosting. Now
even before I made this course, or we got this
grant with Free Code Camp, I actually use hosting
or for some of my personal sites, and I had a
really good experience with them. Some things
about hosting or is if you get the right type of
subscription, you can get a free domain lifetime
SSL and DDoS protection. But just so you know,
everything I teach in this course will work
with other hosting providers as well. So you
don't have to go with hosting. So let's just
click Start down, start now. And there's a few
different options here. If you're just starting
out, I would recommend just the cheapest option,
you can always upgrade later if you need
to. But see, this includes one website,
and then the next one up includes 100 websites,
but we're just making one website. So just select
that one. And then you choose just how long you
want to sign up for, you're probably going to
want at least 12 months, but you may want the 24
months or the 40 months to get a different deal.
And then you can just enter all your information.
Now I'm not going to go through all this right
now, because I already have an account, I
just want to show you what you have to do.
So I want me to sign into my account, and then
I can show you what's gonna what's gonna look
like after you get signed in. Okay, once
you get signed in, you can get your domain,
you may have already gotten your domain in
the process of signing up for your hosting
provider. But if not, you may have to get your
domain afterwards. And just so you know, it is
possible to buy a domain from one company and get
your hosting from a different company and connect
them. But for this tutorial, we're just showing
how you would get your domain name from the same
company as the hosting. So I'll just click Claim
domain. And the here is where you you may have to
search through quite a few domains to find one
that's not already taken. Let me just try some
about robot clothing, no robot attire.
Okay, we got one that WORKED robot attire because
this is going to be a clothing store. Okay,
I'm going to claim the domain. Let's get
this set up. And this is just on my own
personal and I'll just finish registration.
Okay, now I can start creating the website.
And it's pending verification. So I just
need to go and click the link in my email.
And make sure you turn on this who has privacy
or anybody can look up your your information.
And you could be getting a lot of email
spam emails, even like letters to your
address. Let me show you how to create a
custom email from your domain. So I'm under
hosting or domain overview. If I scroll
down here, I can go to manage email.
Here I am going to create a new email account.
So I'm going to add email account and it's just
going to be info at robot attire.com. And
then I'll create a password And then create.
If I click on webmail, it will open up to where
I can log in. And here, once I get logged in,
I can send and receive email from info at robot
tire.com. Okay, let me go back to the home here.
And I'm going to set up the premium shared
hosting. This is where we'll install WordPress
you can go to the survey.
And here is where you can choose to just install
WordPress, or in chaw install WordPress plus
WooCommerce. And that's what we want to do,
we want to install WooCommerce and WordPress,
because WooCommerce is going to power
the store that runs on WordPress.
And then just create an account here.
And you can just pick a template right here, I'm
actually going to install the template later,
just so you can see how you would do if you don't
have hosting. Or if you're not using hosting,
or if you're using a different hosting
provider, you may not get a chance to
pick a template right here, and you may have
to do it later. So that's what we're gonna do.
And we'll just connect it right to robot
attire.com. Okay, I'll finish the setup.
And again, you can install WordPress, even if you
don't have hosting, or most of the popular hosting
providers have a way to install WordPress, it
just can be slightly different. Depending on what
hosting provider you get. After the website is set
up, you may go right into the place where you're
managing it. But if not, you can always go back
to the homepage here and hosting or and then click
Manage. Now in this page is going to give you
all the information about your page like the IP
address. And it's like the domain name, and the
name servers. And also, if you're using a hosting
provider that's not hosting her, there's probably
a page that looks kind of like this, which is
where you actually install WordPress. So you
will probably get into some sort of managing site
just like this. And there will likely be a button
somewhere down here that says Install WordPress or
says WordPress or something like that. So if you
can't, if you don't install WordPress, when you're
originally setting up your page, there may be some
other way to do it. But once you have installed
WordPress, then it's pretty straightforward.
I'm going to click on Dashboard right here.
And then once I'm get to dashboard,
I'm just going to click Edit website.
We purchased the domain name and hosting
and installed WordPress and WooCommerce.
Now let's customize the store. Now let me
minimize the page a little bit. So you can
actually see the URL bar here. Now, whenever
you create any sort of WordPress website,
to get to the admin page, where you actually
make all the edits on your WordPress site,
it's always the same, it's going to
be the URL that you previously chose.
And it's going to be slash WP dash admin.
And then when you get to that, you'll log
in. Now I'm already logged in. But if you're not
logged in, you'll be logged into the admin page.
And then you can start making changes on your
WordPress account. As soon as we get into here,
there'll be some special notifications, it
talks about setting up the website analytics,
and it says Welcome to WordPress, well, we
can just dismiss that some of these you can
just dismiss now this one, your store does
not appear to be using a secure connection.
This is important, especially when you're going
to create a store, you want it to be over a secure
connection. It says we highly recommend serving
your entire website over an HTTPS connection.
Now let me show you how to do that. So I'm
gonna go back to the hosting or admin page,
and look where it says force HTTPS, redirect all
websites over HTTPS. So I'm going to turn that on.
And then it's going to allow us to install the SSL
certificate. Now pretty much all hosting providers
are going to give you this option somewhere.
But it could be in a different place. So I'm
going to say install SSL. Now it says HTTPS
will be automatically forced on your domain.
So instead of HTTP colon slash slash, it's
at https colon slash slash robot attire.com.
S means secure. So we'll close that. And now
I'll just go back over here. If I just refresh
this it's gonna let me log in again, because
now we're in the secure version of the website.
Now you can see this lock is six one,
the secure version of the website.
And if we click this, you'll see
connection is secure. So we're
in HTTPS, which is good, and we don't
see that warning anymore over here.
Okay, before we start setting things up, let's
see what the website actually Looks like with all
the default settings here. So I'm just going
to click where it says, I'm going to mouse
over where it says robot attire.com and click
Visit Site. Okay, so this is the default site,
I'm going to go back to the admin page. And then
this time, I'm gonna try going to visit store.
Okay, so this is the default store. Now,
obviously, the site, the store don't look
anything like what we want to look like, we're
going to be doing a lot of updating. So I'm going
to show you how to edit this site. So it looks
exactly how we want to look. And now you can see
this top bar here. That's because we're logged
into WordPress. And it just anybody that goes
to a website isn't going to see this top bar. But
since we're logged into WordPress, we see that top
bar because we're the administrator, so we can do
special things like at Site customize, I'm going
to show you what all these things are later. But
if we go back into the URL, we can see this is
the shop URL, but we can go back to the main URL
just by changing the URL in here. So I'm going to
show you how to update all this to be exactly
what we want to look exactly how we want to
look. But first, let's go back into the dashboard.
Before we saw what the website already looks like,
and it didn't look that nice. So we are going to
install a theme and a template to just get a basic
look for our site. And then we can customize it.
Now a lot of these things that I'm going to show
you the order doesn't really matter like we could
set up, we could do the WooCommerce setup now.
But we're going to do that in a little bit. We
are going to right now go to appearance. And let
me just zoom in a little more, so it's easier to
see everything. Anytime you're using WordPress,
you're going to use some sort of theme. Now,
it has this 2022 As a default theme here.
But there's tons of different themes that you can
use. I'm just gonna close that for now. And then
I'm going to go to add new theme. So there's a
bunch of really good thing like Astra I think
this is one of the most popular themes out there.
With Ocean WP, I showed how to use this in my
previous WordPress tutorial. For this one,
we're going to use one called Block C. Now,
a lot of the themes work well with E commerce
sites. But this one in particular, I found
has a lot of good features for E commerce sites,
I'm just going to go and install that theme.
And then after it's installed,
just click Activate.
And then I'm going to install the block
C companion. It says right here that it
includes custom extensions, demo templates, and
many, many other awesome features. And we're going
to be using one of the the demo templates.
So let's install the block C companion.
Okay. Now if you want to, if you want
to give them all this extra information,
you can but I'm just going to skip there. But if
you want to allow and continue you can. And now
I'm going to go to starter sites. So what's cool
is that has all these starter sites that you can
install for free. So we can install one of these
starter sites. And then we can go through and
edit it as much as we want. So we can use one
of these sites as our base site. And then we
can then customize it to meet us our to meet our
exact needs. So you're going to want to go through
all these and try to figure out which one looks
most similar to what you want your website to be.
Well, I'm going to just choose this garter robe,
I kind of like that already focuses on clothing.
And my site is going to focus on clothing. But
you can use any of these. And you can make, like,
for example, see, this one's called Petzi, you
can use Petzi, even if you're not going to be
having a website focused on Petzi or focus
on pets. Because once we get this installed,
we can do a bunch of edits and
make it custom for our specific
use case. So I'm going to import this one.
And then we'll install the child theme also.
And then we can choose which page builder we
want to use. There's the Gutenberg page builder
and Elementor page builder. Now Gutenberg is the
default page builder that comes with WordPress
in Elementor. Is is an is an extra page where like
an add on a special page builder. And most people
agree that Elementor is a little easier to use.
So if you're a beginner, I would recommend using
Elementor. And I'm going to show you how to use
it later in this course. So just click next here,
and it's going to install Elementor WooCommerce
is already installed. And then it's going to
install WP forms. So let's click Next. We'll just
import all the content and install everything.
Ok, Starter Site imported successfully. So let's
view the site. Okay, so remember what our site
looked like before. Well now this is what it looks
like. So the Starter Site included some images,
and then it has all these things. It even
has some sample products right in here.
And I'm going to show you in a little bit how to
update all these how to Change all these things
to your products in your images. But it's
nice just to have something to start with,
that we can customize for our purposes. And you
can see all the text is just lorem ipsum. So it's
a sample text that will will update with our
own products. So one thing, let's go up here,
and I'm just going to click on a product. So you
can see what it looks like. If we click on here,
we can see the product page. And you can see
this on sale, not only $30. Now it's $45.
And it even has a review. So users are going
to be able to enter their own reviews for your
for your store when they buy products,
and it shows the top rated products.
And then we can even see what happens if we add
this to cart. So let's just add this to the cart,
view the cart. And then we even have a checkout
cart here. And you can have coupon codes,
then we can proceed to checkout,
and even taken the billing details.
And it says right here, sorry, it seems that there
are no available payment methods for your state,
we're going to have to set up the payment methods,
which I'll show you how to do. And I can't even
show you what it's like to place order until
we get the payment methods. Right now we have
invalid payment methods. Because we don't even we
haven't even set up any payment methods. But let's
see what else we have. We have the products. And
you can see on the main product page, we actually
have a filter, you can filter by price. And we
can see the different products, we have services,
which will be custom will be specific to your
store. And you may not even need this page.
Depending on what store you're trying to create.
You may want to show what special services your
store offers. And then there's the about us page,
there's a news page. This is basically a blog.
And so we can see all these sample blog
entries here and then a contact page.
And you can see how it's always giving
products trying to sell things on every page.
And then we can even search for things.
So I'm going to search for a hat.
Okay, they came up with nothing. Let's try
a watch, I saw that there's definitely a
watching the sample products here.
And even comes up right here.
Okay, so people can search
for the products they want.
So this is a pretty nice store here. So now let's
see how to customize it. So it's specific to your
store your product and what you want it to look
like. So let's go back to the dashboard. Soon I'm
going to show you how to customize your store and
add custom products. But first, let's finish this
WooCommerce setup. So I'm going to click start
selling. And it's going to guide us through some
setup things. First, we're going to going to put
our address, if you look right here, it says this
is going to help configure currency options and
shipping rules automatically. And this will not be
publicly visible and can be easily changed later.
So you don't have to enter, enter this, you can
set up the shipping rules and currency manually.
But I'm just going to enter some information here.
And then you can choose what are you going to
sell physical products, downloadable products
or subscriptions? I'm just gonna do physical
products and downloads and then continue
and then you choose like how many
products you're going to have
and then they they try kind of upsell you it's
not it's It's actually free plugins, but they
try to suggest what are the things you want to add
for now we're not going to add any of those. And
we can always add things later. And then it's
going to ask you if you want to to this theme,
but we already did that. So let's
continue with the active theme.
In we're gonna come back to all this in a
little bit the setting up payments, taxes
shipping, we're after we customize our store,
we're gonna come back and set up all these things.
Now let's go back to the on the side, we have the
WooCommerce and we're gonna go to settings, and
you're probably going to want to update some
of the settings in here. So selling locations,
where do you want to sell to? This may change
depending on what do you want to ship to like you
can actually type in different specific countries
sell to specific countries. And then you can just
type in type in the countries here like let's see,
I'm going to sell to the United States of Canada
and ZICO. That way don't have to ship across an
ocean. Or you can just choose all countries or
whatever countries you want to sell to. And then
shipping locations. So sell the specific coming
countries, that means we're selling to people
that are there live in specific countries,
but you may not want to ship to the
same locations that you're selling to,
it's usually going to be the same. That's why the
default is shipped to all countries you sell to,
and the default customer location. Where
do you think most people are going to
be? Now you could do geo locate, if you click geo
locate, the browser will try to figure out where
the user is located. And then we'll set the
default location to wherever the browser
says they're currently located. So I'm actually
just going to do shop Country region, so it will
default to the United States where I'm from. And
then I am going to enable tax rate calculations
that we'll set up more later able to use a coupon
code, you can decide whether you want to do that.
And then you can choose the currency options. So
I'll just save changes for this. Now go to the
Products page. Some of the things you're gonna
want to choose here are the weight units. Well,
since I'm in the United States, I'll choose
pounds, but probably most people are going to
choose kilograms. If you're somewhere else in the
world dimension units, I'll just choose inches.
And you can choose if you want enable reviews,
if you want to enable star rating, other save
what we have here, and then you're probably
going to want to go to inventory here too.
And so in inventory, you can determine whether
you're going to enable stock management. So
I can just turn that off. And we won't ever
tell how much you have in stock. Or you can
set all these things based on when something
is low stock when something is out of stock,
you can also change things for the downloadable
products. And for the down little products,
you can determine whether you have to
download, you can do downloads Require Login,
are you going to grant access to downloadable
products after payment, you're likely going
to want to say keep all this as the default
settings. But you can change it if you want.
Now tax we're going to talk more about tax
later. But you can see there's settings for tax
shipping, we're gonna set payments for the store
later. And then accounts and privacy. Do you want
to allow customers to place order without an
account, probably you want to give customers
as much freedom and flexibility as possible.
So they'll be more likely to go through and buy
products allow I'm going to allow customers
to create an account while customers create an
account on the My Account page we want them to
be just do as much as they possibly can. Yeah,
we want them to be able to log into an existing
countering checkout if they have an account.
And then here, it's going to link to
the privacy policy, which we are going
to be able to create later. And then let's go to
emails, oops, I've got 10. Remember to save this.
So here are where you can see the emails that
are sent out when someone makes an order,
and you can update what emails are sent
out based on different things happening
in your store. And the rest of this we won't do
anything with. So let's go back to our dashboard.
Now I'm going to teach you how to customize
your site. So it's specific to your brand.
So I'm going to go back into Visit Site.
And I'm going to show you how to customize
every part of this site. And then afterwards,
I'll show you how to add your custom items.
While we're customizing the site, we're just
going to use all the sample items and sample
data that's already there. But then afterwards,
we'll delete all the sample data. So we can start
adding your real products. So if you remember,
we installed the Elementor page builder, that's
what I'm going to show you how to use now. So in
this top bar when I click edit with Elementor.
And if you get this depending on how you
set your site, you may have to recreate
the kit. So we'll do that now. We're going
to recreate the kit and then save changes.
You may not even have to do that step.
But now let me go back to the site.
And then edit with Elementor. There's always new
versions of Elementor. So you may get something
telling you about some new version of Elementor.
But you can just click through that got it. So
now we can see the site. And then over on the
left side are all the different elements we can
edit with. But look what we can do. But we can
actually click any of these elements and start
editing. So it says brand new collection will I
can actually just select this. And then I'm going
to type in robots, robot clothes are fun. And you
can put anything you want here your store slogan,
or this is just for fun. I'm just kind of giving
you example here, but you can change what this
looks like, I can go to style. So I can actually
change the color if I want to change it to a
specific color. Or even better if you don't
want to, instead of just picking any color,
it's better if your site has specific colors,
you don't want to use tons of colors everywhere,
you want to stick to just a few colors on your
whole site. So that's easy to do by I can click
one of these global colors. I'm going to do theme
color for but later I'll show you how to change
those theme colors. So when you change the theme
colors, and all the places like for instance,
one of the theme colors is red. And if I change
the theme color to a different color, all the red
will change to a different color. But for now,
I'm going to continue doing some edits on here.
So here is where you can change the font size,
weight and all this stuff, you can change the
style, like if it's bold, or italicized,
I'm actually going to change this to normal.
And then I'm going to make this a little smaller,
because I want this to just be on two lines. And
you can even change like the line height how
much space is between the lines, letter spacing.
And there's just a lot of different settings you
can you can change to make it so it works for your
specific brand. You can even add a text shadow. So
that's what I'm going to try adding a shadow here.
And we can kind of change where
the shadow is going to be.
And you don't have to edit shadows just some
interesting things that make it stand out and make
it specific to your your store. So I'm gonna go
to Advanced here. And this is where you can change
different margin. So margin is going to be so
margin and padding are both going to have to
do with how much space are around the words. So
I'm going to change the the margin on the side.
And you can see it's all going together because
it's locked. But if we unlink the values, then
we can just change one or you don't have to change
them all at the same time. So I can put this back
to zero, this can be zero, and then we can just
change the left margin to go to the side. And it's
gonna work the same with padding. So if I unlink,
this, I can change the padding on the left side.
And then there's all these other things, you can
do that to the text like any of this stuff here,
you can do to any text on the whole page. So you
can make an interest animation so it fades in.
So as soon as you scroll down to see these
words, the text can fade in. And there's
all these different options we can make it
bounce in, we can make it slide to the left.
And you're probably not going to want to do
that for your main title. But this is just an
example. Because you can go through in every text
like this new arrivals, you can make it slide in
as soon as the person scrolls down. So you can
just experiment with all these different settings,
you can like for instance, you can change
the background. So we can put an image in
the background, or we can do a specific
color, so I can make it a red background.
I'll clear that though. Or you can actually put
an image in the background like for instance,
over here we have a background image. And I'll
show you how to change that for a little bit.
So there's these all these different things to
easily customize it to be exactly how you want it.
So here we can see these three different
things with three different icons. Well,
instead of a checkmark, I want to
change this icon, I'm gonna go to the
icon library. And I can change this I
can, let's see, where's the search here.
Obviously, I'm going to choose a robot for the
icon because this is all about robot clothes.
And I can change this, I can do
the same thing for all these icons.
Now I'm going to show you some settings that
change stuff on your whole site. So if I click the
this hamburger menu, I can go to Site Settings.
So here you can change things that are going to
impact things all over your site. Now depending
on what your theme is, it may not change things,
because you may have a theme that overrides some
of these settings. But some things are pretty
important, like the site identity, let's go to
site identity, I'm going to change this site
name will show up in the top bar of your website.
So insert my URL here, I'm gonna be called robot
tire. And then a site description. This is
something that could show up on some search
engines, and then some other places. So instead of
putting just another WordPress site, I'm gonna say
best place best store for robot attire. And then
logo. This is where we can change our logo. So to
switch the logo on the site, we're just going to
click here the Choose Image. First, you have to
have your logo made, I would recommend a site like
fiverr.com where you can hire someone to make a
a logo for you for $5. I've actually used
that for some other sites that I've created,
but also sometimes I just create my own logos.
In this case I I've already created a logo.
So I'm gonna just go to choose
image. And I'm going to upload it.
And I'm going to select it and it's uploading.
And I will, I'll just put a logo. And then here's
where you can also add a favicon. That's the
icon that will appear on the tab on your browser.
So you can choose an icon, there's plenty of
websites that you can go to that you can upload
a picture, and it will, it will give you a favicon
file that you can upload right into here. So what
I'm going to do is update the site settings.
And hopefully we'll see it right on here.
Now we can see that the logo didn't change
in WordPress, because of how the page builder
works together with the theme works together
with just the standard WordPress design,
there could be multiple places to change different
things. And depending on what theme you're using,
the only way to find out for sure how to change
things is through trial and error. So we can see
that changing the site logo here did not change
the logo, there's one other place we can change.
And when we go to this other place, there's
actually quite a few other things we can
change there. So let me show you how to get to
there. So what we're gonna do is just close this.
And then I'm going to click the little hamburger
menu and then click Exit to dashboard. And then
we just need to go to this the WordPress logo
here. And now we go to appearance. And under
Appearance I'm going to go to Customize, this
is going to enable a whole new section of things
that we can customize. So I'm going to go to the
header because we're changing the header here.
And then you can see it's showing different things
we have here. So eight, when it says the top row,
that's this row appear, this is the top row where
it says Don't miss our holiday offer 20% off, and
then it has the the social media things. And then
we have the main row here, which so it says logo,
and then it has the menu, it has the search
account card, that's the search account card
over here. So I'm just going to click where
it says menu. Now you can see the logo here,
this is the old logo, I'm going to click this edit
button. And then I can just choose the new logo.
Okay, now we see the new logo right up here.
And there's different settings you can do,
we can change the height of the logo, so too big.
And you can change how it's aligned. Now, while
we're on this page, let me show you what some of
the other things you can do. Okay, so let's now
change this top bar here. So one thing I want
to do is change the social media. So if I click
social media here, here's where we can add what
social media we want to add, like, we may not
want to, we may not want to have a phone number,
we probably want to have an email. So I'm just
going to have, I'm just going to have Twitter
and Facebook. And then as you can see, they go
away here. Now we only have the two links here.
And then it says, configure the social links in
general layout social network accounts. So let
me show you how to do that. We're going to go back
here, General, and then social network accounts.
And there's all these, you can just add what your
social network account is here. So for email,
I'll just put my email address, and then we can
go back to the other one, which is the Twitter.
And you can add, and I'll just put HTTP s,
colon, slash slash twitter.com/beau Carnes,
but you may have a social media account directly
for your your store. And then here's some other
things we can do. I am going to go back here.
And this is a pretty important thing here.
If I go to Where's oh, I need to go back
again. And then we go to colors. This is where
you can change the colors throughout your whole
store. Now I decided to go ahead and use the red.
That's why I made the logo red there. But if you
don't want to see all these buttons that are red,
if I go into this color palette, or actually not
there, if I just actually click this color color
one, I can change this to blue, and see every
place on the site that was red is now blue.
See, and then you can change see that red
there? Well, let's go to Color to I think
that could be the hover color. Let's find if I
change the green. Let's see what now if I hover
now it's going to hover as green and
see where this gray here that kind of
looks like this. Let's see if I change this.
What happens if I change this to red? Oh no,
but it did change this text down here. We'll
keep that and see even this becomes blue here
but since I have the red as the logo, I'm
going to change the main color back to red.
But you can change the colors for your website
to match whatever you have as your logo.
And then you can see you can change the color of
different things here, the different headings,
what color the links are going to be.
But I'm gonna go back over here. So here,
you can change the header and the footer, and
stuff like that. But to really change the header,
you can just click here and change the
header, because if I click on menu here,
it's not going to change the menu items. So if
I want to change the menu items in the header,
there's somewhere else I have to do, I have to
go to do that. So let me click publish. So we
published with our new color and the logo here.
And then I'm going to hit X to go out of this,
when we go back over here. Now if I go to
Appearance, Menus, this is where we can choose
what things show up in the menu, we're not going
to show services. So I'm going to remove services,
I'm going to remove news. And we're just going
to have the products, the Home Products about us
and contact. So the real thing that
a lot of you care about is the shop
page. So let's just quickly show you how to
edit the about us page and the contact page.
And then we will go to the shop page. So I'm
going to go back to visiting the site. And now if
we go to about us. Now here on the About Us page,
you can just edit it just like we had the
other page, I'm going to edit with Elementor.
And I'm just going to delete this entire
section here, I'm just going to the x bar here.
And you can see there, this top section is really
big. Now that I deleted that little section this,
this about us thing, there's a lot of
space down here. So I'm going to go here
to this Edit section. Nowhere style.
X will go to advanced. And you can see
the padding, the padding is why there's
so much blank space here, I'm just
going to change this to zero. So 00.
And then we have teams, you can change that these
pictures, you can change this text to your team
names, you can update and remove things just like
we did on the other page. Okay, let's go to the
contact page. Oh, and before I forget that, when
you make changes, it doesn't actually make the
changes until you click update. So I'm gonna
click the Update down here. And then we'll go
to the contact page. So here's our contact form.
Now you can edit with Elementor, just like we've
seen, but let me show you how you would
actually edit what fields are in this form.
I'm going to go up to WP forms right here. And
I'm going to a simple contact form, edit form.
Now I can add things to remove things like phone,
we don't need to know the person's phone number.
Okay, we do need to know that email address.
And I can get something new like I mean,
when I use some checkboxes, I'm going to
click this checkbox and drag it over here.
And then I can edit it. So reason
for contact website, question. Sales
want a cookie. Now I can save that. But before I
go back to my contact page, I'm going to settings
and notifications. And make sure this is on.
Sometimes we'll be off you want to make sure these
notifications are on. And this is going
to send to your admin email address.
So I'm going to save this will access now I'll
go back to my contact page. And we'll try it out
and I do want a cookie. Hello. Now click Send
Message. Now go to my email address. This is
info at robot attire.com which is my current admin
email. Go in here. And here. I want a cookie.
Hello, I got the email. Well, that works. Let's
check out this header. There's still some menu
items that I thought were removed. So let me go
back over to the dashboard. Appearance Menus. And
I did not save the menu last time that was
the problem. So let me Move this, move that.
And then we'll save the menu. And
this time, it will hopefully work.
Okay, that looks good. Okay, we finally reached
the part you've been waiting for the product
page. So let me show you how you can change
the product page. Now you can see there is no
edit with Elementor up here. So we can only click
Customize. Now I'm going to scroll down here
to where it says WooCommerce. The
product page is through WooCommerce.
So here we can change things like the
other three columns here, well, what I
can add additional columns of products, I can
do two columns. And then we can change how many
rows right now there are four rows,
we may want to only have three rows.
You can also change the fiscal, what
type of the shop is going to look like.
There's some just some minor differences between
each of these styles. And we can change how it's
going to sort what kind of sidebar we're going
to have. So right now we have the filter, we can,
we can filter. So we can just show the products.
Or we can turn back on the sidebar, we can filter
by different but in different ways. So you can go
through here and change things, I'm going to turn
off this page title. So when you click products,
it's going to go right to the store page right
here. And another thing we're going you can do
from here is change what a single product page
looks like. So let me go into this black T shirt
product page. And we can change what this product
page looks like. So here's some things we can see
what the top rated products is on one side, we can
click here to make it switch sides. Maybe we don't
want that top rated products, we can turn that off
by clicking the narrow width, I'm going to
go back to the the right sidebar one and
then see sale bad. So see how it says
sale up there, we can turn that off
and turn it back on, we can choose whether it's
gonna show the star rating, the metadata, and go
to product gallery. And I can change see how it
zooms I go over it? Well, I can turn that off. So
now when I scroll over is not going to zoom into
the product. So you can play around with these
settings until you get your product page looking
exactly how you want to look how you want to look.
Okay, when you're editing a product page,
let me show you how you would edit these,
the sidebar here. And then also the reviews.
Well, the reviews, I already actually showed
you a while back how to turn on and off reviews
that's in the WooCommerce settings, you can
say you can turn off reviews for everything
or turn on reviews for everything right now
they're turned on, let me show you how you
would update this sidebar right here. Because
I don't really like this black box right
here. I do kind of like the related products,
but I don't like this new cloth technologies
box. So to do that, I'm going to have to go
to the the main WordPress dashboard, I'm gonna go
to Appearance and Widgets, that sidebar is under
widgets. So the specific widget
is actually this WooCommerce
sidebar, and we have the top RED project
products that we saw on here. And then we had
this whole thing right here. So I'm just going
to click this, and then click Delete. So now
we're only going to have the top rated products
and see when I click into top rated products,
you can choose what the title of this
is gonna be, how many products to show,
and stuff like that. And also, I'm gonna
go up here and I'm also going to delete
this in the main sidebar, I'm going to
delete this black thing right here. And
then you can add anything else you want to the
sidebar, and then I'm going to click update.
Now we can go back over to that. Oh, really
quick, I'll show you one more time how you
would turn off the the comments. If you go to
WooCommerce settings here, and then you go to
products, and then you can disable that
enable product reviews, you can turn off.
Okay, we'll just go back to here Visit Site.
Now if we go back to a product page. Now we
don't have that black thing right there.
Another thing we can do is change what the
shopping cart looks like. So I'm going
to click the shopping cart right here.
So we can go to the checkout page, and they can
click Proceed to Checkout here. And now we can
we can change what the checkout page looks like.
Like for instance, I can turn on the coupon form.
And now, people can choose if they have a
coupon they can do click here to enter the code.
And then you can check, like
what's going to be required here.
And you can, you can also choose what, what's
gonna show up about your privacy policy. And
this is the link to the privacy policy page, which
we still have to edit, I'm actually going to open
up this into a new tab really quick, so I can, so
we can show you how to edit the privacy policy.
So to edit this privacy policy, I'm going
to go back into the main WordPress menu,
I'm going to go to pages. And then I'm going
to find the privacy policy page, edit this.
And now we can add the privacy policy, I'm
just going to use all the suggested text.
So I'm just going to delete
where it says suggested text.
And then I can click publish. Okay, now I want to
make sure I'm using this right, privacy policy my
my checkout page, let's go back to the checkout
page. And there's a few privacy, I'm gonna
choose this first privacy policy. And then we'll
just click it to make sure it's the right one.
Okay, that's the right one. And then make sure
you click Publish here. So any changes, you always
want to click Publish to make sure all the changes
happen, that ecommerce site is starting to look
pretty good. Now let's see how to add products
to the store. So in order to add some custom
products, we're going to go back to the main, the
main dashboard. And I'm going to click where it
says products here for do this, so it keeps saying
keep suggesting that we connect monster insights,
a setup website analytics. Now if we click here,
it's going to go, it's going to actually walk us
through all the steps that's outside the scope
of this particular tutorial. So I should have
done this earlier. But what I'm going to do
is, is delete this plugin, so we don't have
to keep seeing it, we're going to go to plugins.
So before you can delete a pro plug in, you have
to deactivate it. So I'm going to deactivate
this plugin, and then I am going to check it.
And then I'm going to just click Delete.
And then if I refresh this page, oh,
and to get I guess there's one more thing
we have to remove, let's deactivate this.
And then delete it.
Now, it's no longer showing that message.
Good. So let's go back to the products again.
The first thing we're going to do is just remove
all the products that are currently there.
So I'm just going to click this. And then we
are going to move to trash. And click Apply.
Okay, now we can just start
adding some products from scratch.
So the first type of product I'm going to
teach you how to create is a simple product.
So this is a simple product, it has a picture,
sometimes there can be additional pictures below,
we only have one picture for this one, it has
a title as a description, and then down here,
it's going to have a more detailed description.
So let me show you how you create a product like
this. It's simple, because there are no options
that you would have to choose. So let's go back
to the main dashboard. So I'm going to click
add new to add a new product, robot hat.
And then we can add the description. So
this description is the description that
appears second on the page, that will just contain
additional information about the product because
the user will have already read a description.
And so this could be like made in the USA,
you will not want to return this. And then if
we scroll down here to this other description,
this is the description that the customer
will see first, the short description.
So I'm just going to paste in a description
for the robot hat. I'm gonna go back up here
and make sure we have simple product chosen
here. It's not virtual or downloadable,
but we could make a downloadable product.
And then we can put the full price but $50
and then we can put the sale price we can also
schedule how long the sale is going to happen for
so I can say that it's going to start today,
and it's going to go for a week. So then after
That time is up, it won't show that sales price
anymore. So let's go to inventory, you can have
a SKU number if you have a specific number for
the product, and then there's also manage stock.
So if you have managed stock, you'll keep track
of how much you have in stock. So I can say 10.
And then if you have a stock on the product page
will actually tell how many are left in stock.
And then do you want to allow people to purchase
it after it's not in stock and create a backorder.
And then you can also choose if you want to
be sold individually. And then you can put
information about the shipping, like the weight,
the dimensions, and then you can choose a shipping
class was we don't have any setup right now. Also,
you can choose linked products. Now remember,
on the product page where there was some products
on the side, there's products on the bottom,
this is where you set those products. Now I don't
actually, this is the first product I'm creating.
So I don't have anything to add. But once you
add a bunch of products, you can select which
things are going to be considered upsells, in
which things are going to be considered cross
sells. So it will suggest the other products
to users at various times. And then we have
attributes which we will talk more later when we
get to some of these other types of products. And
then advance a purchase note is a note that will
be sent to the customer after they purchase it.
Now menu order, this changes how far up in on
your page will show. So when you have a bunch
of different products on your page, the lower
this number, the higher it appears on the page.
So the products you want to show to the user the
most you want to have a lower number. And we have
the reviews enabled for all the products,
but you can turn off reviews for individual
products here. And then we already talked about
this description. Okay, the next thing we're going
to do is add the product image. So go up here, set
a product image. And I'm going to upload a file.
And here's my product image, this robot hat. And
then if you have other images, that won't be the
main image, you can add them here the product
gallery images, product tags, you want to give
similar items, the same tag, like I'll add hat
for this. And then if we add any other hats,
we'll use the same tag. And then people can click
the word hat, and they can see all the hats.
And then we're also going to add this to the
accessories category. Now another thing to
just have all the accessories in the category
all t shirts in the same category, and so on.
Now, I kind of skipped over this before, but this
gives you information about SEO and you can change
the different descriptions and titles and
and try to adjust the snippets are going to
appear on so on search engines and other places
on the web. But we're not going to go into that
right now. Right now, I'm just gonna go and click
publish. And we've now created a simple product.
Our product is created. So
let's check it out. So it says
we can click on View Product right here.
And we'll open up the product page.
So here's the hat here, we got the title we
put in. And so as it's on sale, here's the
description, and we have 10 in stock. And then it
shows our category and our tags here. If we click
accessory, we can see all the accessories.
Currently there's no other accessories. But
we can go back to the product page. And then you
can see here's the additional description here.
And here's three views, I can even leave a review
right now. Best hat ever, and then click Submit.
And right now I'm logged in, it'll show the
company I'm logged in at. So the your users will
be able to create their own account on the store,
and then they will be able to leave reviews.
So we have our simple product. Now we're going to
create a variable product. A variable product is
just a product where you can change the options.
You can maybe change the color or change the size.
But like do you want to medium size a large size
small size blue red. So let me show you how to
create a variable product, we could go back to the
product page. But even right on this page, there's
a there's a new thing we can click on New and then
product so we're creating a new product right now.
And I'm going to call this a robot shirt. We're
going to have different colors and different
sizes of shirts. So to create a variable product
we'll put in the description made in your country.
And we're going to go down and we can just
put the the full description okay, we've got
the description. So now we're going to click it
says symbol progress and click this and go to
variable product. So some of the is going
to be the same. But now we are going to have
attributes and variations. So let's go to the
attributes. And I'm going to add an attribute,
the first is going to be size. And then it says
right here into some tax, and it shows to use
this to separate the attributes. This is
not an eye, it's actually a vertical bar,
it's on your keyboard, right on the same key as
the backslash. So I'm going to put small, medium,
large. Okay, I'll save the attribute. And then
I'm going to add another one, which is going to be
color. And we'll do red, and blue. And I'll save
this. Okay, so now I have a customer will be
to choose the size and the color of the shirt.
Okay, so now I'm going to save the attributes.
Now go to variations, and it says you need
to add some variations on the Attributes tab,
that we need to go back to the attributes.
And there's one thing we forgot, which is
to click this button that says that says use
for variations. And for color, let me put that
down use for variations. We'll save that. Now
we'll go back to variations. And at this point,
we can click this drop down menu and
create variations from all attributes.
And then I'll say are you sure you want
to do this? Yes, we want to do that.
And it's added six variations. Okay, so it's added
for every, it's added every size and every color.
Now here is where it gets kind of tedious, we're
going to add to add information for every single
variation. So we are going so all these
options are very similar to the simple product
options. And we're going to have to add these for
every variation. So for price for the small, it's
going to be $20. In stock, you can add weights,
if you want, we go up here and click this image,
we can upload an image. Now I'm going to upload
a few files here. And I'm uploading a blue shirt,
a picture of a blue shirt and a picture of a red
shirt. And then I'll set this as the variation.
So for this small red shirt, we're going to show
the red shirt here. And then we have to go through
for all these other ones. So for the small blue
shirt, I'm going to add the blue shirt here,
and it's going to be $20. And then we'll just keep
going down here. And for the medium, it's going to
be the same, it's just going to select the same
image, this time, I'm going to put a different
different price. So this is going to be $25. The
meeting will be $25. This is just just to show
an example that you can use different prices
and even different sale prices for different
different variations. I'll make the sale price.
So this register is on sale. So I'll make this
20 Let's say you have more of that type
of shirt that you just need to get rid of.
And then we'll just go through
and set the rest of these.
Okay, after we set all these variations, I'm
going to save changes. And now we can add
everything that you add to the simple product.
Like we can add tags, I'm going to put shirt,
and then I can also go to a category select
teasers for the category. And then you're still
going to want to select a product image. When
a product is initially shown on the store page,
before the customer can choose what type of color
they're looking at, it's gonna have to show just a
single image. So this is the this is going to be
the initial image that's going to be shown will
show the blue. And that reminded me one more
thing. Let's go back over to the variations.
You can also set a default size and a default
color to be selected. So we're going to put a
default size to medium and a default color to
blue, just like it's showing the blue image.
Okay, now we can go up here, and we can publish.
Now let's view the product to see what this
looks like. Okay, see, it's showing it could
be anywhere between 20 and $30, depending on
which size and which color and you can see here's
the blue one. But if I go to a large, it's
gonna it's going to change the price to 30.
If I change the color I continue to read, it
should show the red shirt. And just like before,
well just just like before, we'll have
reviews, there's even additional information,
it's going to show the different sizes
possible and the different colors possible.
And you can see automatically is putting related
products up here. So really I don't have there's
not really very many products so it's just
going to show the products that we already have.
Now we're gonna To create a group product, a group
product is a product where there's a few different
options. And each options come with different
items. Like, say you're selling a camera,
and you'll have a product page for the camera,
but you can select just the camera, or you can
select the camera in the bag, or you can select
a camera bag and tripod. And each group of
each group of items under the product page will
have different prices. So let's see how to do
that. I'm going to go to new product. So to
make a group product, we have to make the main
product and then we have to create all the
sub products that are within the group.
So since this is a robot tire store, what if we
actually sold an actual robot or a robot toy, so
I'm going to put robot toy for the main product.
And then we can just add the descriptions.
Okay, if we add the description, we can
change the product to grouped product.
And then we can add categories. So I
actually already add a new category
category called robot. And then you can add
tags like Toy Fun, and then I'll just add those.
And then we will add an image.
So I've already uploaded this
robot picture. So I'll set that as the
product image, and then I will publish it.
Okay, now we have to create the sub products. So
I'll click Add New, and then I'll put Cosmo robot,
because the robot toys gonna be a cardinal
robot, we already have the description,
so we don't need to add the description, all we
have to do is add the price, which will set as
$100. And then what we want to do is make sure
it's invisible. So right now, this will just
show up on the normal store page. But we want
to click the Edit for the catalog visibility,
and we'll have it hidden. So we'll only show
up as the group product. So I'll publish this.
And now I'll create two more.
So let me just copy this
and add new. So this is gonna
be a cardinal robot plus case.
And then this is just going to be $150. And
then we will put the visibility to hidden.
And then I'll just do one final product, which
will be capital robot plus case plus extra
charger, then this will be $200. And then
I will, again, change the visibility and
publish. Now that we have all these sub products
created, let's go back to our main product page.
And I will select the robot toy, the initial
one and click Edit. Now we'll go down and go to
linked products. And here's where we add all
the linked products. So we have Cardinal robot,
we have Cardinal robot plus case, and we have
customer rep plus case was extra charger, no
this update this product. And now we can
view product to see what it looks like.
Okay, so we have says robot toy. And we can choose
kasma robot, cosmic robot plus case, or Cardinal
probit plus case was at your charger, and you can
see it has the price range of all these prices.
And everything else is basically the
same as the other types of products.
Okay, we're going to learn about one final type
of product, which is a downloadable product. So
I'm going to New and click on product. So
a downloadable product could be an ebook,
it could be an image, it could be a zip file full
of a bunch of different files. And it could be a
song maybe. So we are going to actually
be selling a song or robot song and
and we just add the description
just like all other products
Okay, now we can change from, it's gonna be a
simple product, but we're going to click Virtual
and downloadable. So virtual means that it's not
going to be shipped to anybody and downloadable
means we can choose what the file is to download.
So this is going to be a $3 song. And then I can
add the file that's going to be downloaded. So I'm
gonna go to choose file and then upload the file.
And then I got had this robot song that mp3. And I
don't know why I added all these extra characters
at the end because that wasn't on my computer, but
no problem. So now it actually puts the URL right
in here. And then for the file name, I'm going to
put robot song dot mp3 And then you can choose how
many times a person can download it It's default
to unlimited, but maybe you only want somebody
to download it three times. And then how long will
the download link work? So right now, it will work
forever. But we can make the download link expire
after a certain number of days. Let's give them
one week to download the song. Okay, we'll go up
here. And this add, I'm going to add make this
and accessory, we could make a new category called
the songs. And then for tags, we'll just put song
in it Oh, yeah, also, we're going to need
a picture. So I'm going to set the product
image. Instead of uploading a new image, I'm
just going to pick one that's already in here.
So this looks like so how about this one, see,
this person is actually listening to something. So
we'll set that as the product image because
they're listening to the song right in there.
So now I'm going to publish this
and we'll go to View product. Okay, so if you add
this to cart and exit, go to the checkout, it will
end up giving you a link to download the song.
Our store has products. Now it's time to make so
a customer can actually check out by configuring
payment processing taxes, shipping coupons,
and more. Okay, now we're going to add payments,
we're going to make it so your store can accept
credit cards. And to do that, we're going to
add a new plugins, let's go to the plugins here.
The way we're going to make it so customers
can pay with a credit card is through stripe.
And to do that, we're going to add a new plugin.
So click Add New. And now I'm going to search
for stripe. And then we have the WooCommerce
stripe payment gateway. So let's install that.
Okay, then I'll activate. Now let's
create or login to our Stripe account.
Okay, I'm here@stripe.com. And I'm going to click
sign in and you click that whether you have an
account yet or not. And then I'm going to you can
either sign with your account or you can sign up.
If this is your first time claim
account, you're going to have to verify
a link in your email. The great thing about
stripe is it's completely free to use.
Now I'll go to payments. And these are all the
different things you can set as payments. And I'm
going to turn stripe on and then we can connect
or create a Stripe account to accept payments.
So I'm going to click here connect or create a
Connect account, we already created the account.
And then it's going to go through this, they just
want to verify my phone number. So enter my phone
number here. And now we'll connect the account.
And now we'll just put an information about the
business like address and other things. And then
you can even put your bank account information so
you can get your payout from stripe. Okay, we
got done, I got done putting in all the really
personal information to get this Stripe account
set up and connected. Now we're gonna update what
shows up on your store website when someone's
paying by stripe. Instead of credit card stripe,
let's just call it credit card. People don't
necessarily have to know that it's using Stripe.
And luckily the keys from the Stripe account
automatically got switched over here.
Okay, now we have to we have a few things
disabled that way to fix. So it says that
the payments payouts is disabled until missing
business information is updated. I'm gonna go here
Edit Account keys. And we have to add this URL
to the Stripe account settings. So I'll copy that
endpoint and add the endpoint. We're just going
to listen for all endpoints, I'll click Add events
and then add endpoint. Now we just have to
copy this web hook hook secret and go back
to WooCommerce. And I'm just going to paste
it in right here. And then save live keys.
Okay, we can now accept payments. We can
accept payments. We can't do payouts yet
until we put in a little information, a
little more information on the stripe page.
But we can receive the payments. And
then once we update more information
about like our bank account and stuff
like that, then we can accept the payouts
so on stripe if you want to test it
out, you can enable test mode here
and then when you're done testing it make sure
you turn test mode off and Stripe gives you
some test card numbers. So if I click here gonna
open up these test card numbers that you can use.
So when you're testing your website, you can use
these test numbers. They're not real numbers,
but stripe, you can use this to test an order with
stripe. Okay, let's go back over here, we're going
to set up one more method of payment. So I'm going
to click payment here. And now I'm going to set up
payment with PayPal. So you can set up any of
these types of payments, and it will no matter
which one you pick, it's going to walk you through
that. But for this tutorial, I'm just showing
stripe and PayPal. So I'm going to install another
plugin. So I'm gonna click on plugins here. And
I'm just going to search for or excellent, click
Add New. And then I'm going to search for PayPal.
Okay, WooCommerce PayPal payments, install now.
And Activate. Okay, now I can just go to
WooCommerce, Settings, and then payments. And
then I can come down to where it says PayPal, turn
that on. And then I'm going to connect to PayPal.
Just like with stripe, I'm going to create a
PayPal account, or maybe you already have one,
I'm just going to sign into my PayPal account
that I already have. And you'll have to make
sure it's a PayPal business account. So
I'm gonna create a new business account,
you're going to set up a PayPal business
account. But after you do all that,
you can go back to WordPress. And then
we're going to enable the PayPal gateway.
So you can can't change what is going to look
like. But most of this you can can just keep
the default settings. The only thing you may
want to do is decide whether you're going to
use sandbox mode to test it, or you want to
actually turn it on for real. So we'll leave
sandbox mode off. So we'll have it turned on
for real. And then I'll just save changes. Okay,
now we have two forms of payments, set up stripe
for credit cards. And then we also have PayPal,
we're going to test it all out in a
moment. But first, let's set up the tax.
So to get taxes to work, we have this tax tab
here. But to make it even easier, we're gonna
we're gonna install another plugin. So
I'm going to go down to plugins again.
And this time, I'm just gonna go directly to
add new plugin. And I'm going to search for tax.
And then we're going to look for
WooCommerce shipping and tax.
So this is going to make it much easier to
set up both the shipping and tax. That's
the great thing about WordPress is
that there's plugins for basically
anything to help make different things
easier. Okay, now I'm going to activate it.
And now it's going to say it's going to
tell me to install jetpack and connect.
So to make this easy tax system work, you're
going to have to install jetpack and other thing
and also create a jetpack account. But it's going
to make things way easier to set than the setup
taxes manually for every state installation
failed destination folder already exists. This
could mean that it tried to install and
something messed up in the installation.
And then when it tried to install
again, the folder was already there.
So to actually to remove that the folder,
we're actually going to go back to hosting
her and we're going to have to go to our hosting
account for robot attire. So let me go to manage
and now I'm going to have to go to where we can
actually to access the actual files that make up
WordPress and be able to find that folder and
delete. So let me scroll down a little bit here
and I'm going to go to File Manager
now you have to be very careful when you're in
the file manager because you've messed something
up something here. It can mess up a lot of
things on your website. I'm going to open this
okay now to find wp content. Now plugins
and now I'm going to find jetpack
and I'm just going to delete this jetpack
folder by clicking the Delete button up here.
Okay, now that Jetpack is deleted we
can go back to our hosting our page and
I'm Just going to refresh this so we
can try installing jetpack again. So
I'm going to click install now. Okay to
install, I can just activate this now.
Now I have to set it up. So setup jetpack. Like
I said, I'm going to have to create an account
I'm just going to create an
account with my Google login.
And we can choose any of these paid
plans. But if we scroll down a little bit,
we can just do jet pack free, so we're
just going to use the free version.
And then you just set the
some things here and then
make sure to not choose anything that costs money.
I'm just click dot not now for all these things.
Okay, this is setup, we don't actually
have to get this this plan here.
So I'm going to go back to WooCommerce
and back to settings. Now at the tax
Okay, now we have the option
to enable automated taxes,
this is going to make everything work way easier.
If you don't have automated taxes, you have to set
up the taxes individually for each state, and each
place that you're shipping to or shipping from.
But automated taxes, we'll just figure that out
all on on its own, it will see it says your tax
rate and tags will be automatically configured for
Michigan United States that's right live, if you
live somewhere else, it will just enable it will
just automatically figure out the taxes from where
you're shipping from. And where we're enabling
prices exclusive of tax, so the tax will be added
extra. And then we're going to calculate tax
baseline customer shipping address most of this,
you're just going to use exactly how it's set.
So I'm just going to click Save Changes. Okay,
now we can do something similar with
shipping, I'm gonna go to shipping.
So we're going to create some shipping zones. It
says right here, shipping zone is a geographic
region where a certain set of shipping methods
and rates apply. And we're going to add a shipping
zone. And then you're going to choose where the
zone. So let's make a zipping shipping zone called
United States. And then I'll I'm going to ship
and I'm going to choose United States. So for the
entire United States, we're going to add certain
shipping methods. So the first one, so we have a
few options, we have the flat rate free shipping
or local pickup. So I'm gonna click add shipping
method for a flat rate. Now I can edit this. So
some places, depending on where you're located,
sometimes shipping will be taxable. And a lot of
places it's not suddenly click none, but you'll
you're gonna have to look at your area wherever
you're based off out to see if you should tax
the shipping or not. So I'm going to put a flat
rate of just about $6. And I'll save the changes.
Now we can add another shipping method. So let's
say we have free shipping, but we only want free
shipping as someone spends enough money. So I'm
gonna go to edit. And free shipping requires what
does it require? Well, maybe a shipping coupon,
we'll talk about coupons in a little bit here,
or maybe a minimum order amount, you can see
there's different options, I'm gonna do a minimum
order amount, so I'm going to make someone spend
at least $30 to get free shipping. When do coupons
apply are going to apply minimum order rule before
the coupon discount or after the coupon discount
Moses to after the coupon discount, and
then click Save Changes. So now people
have the option of the flat rate or the free
shipping. So we added this shipping zone,
we're also going to add another shipping zone. So
I'm gonna click shipping zone here. And then we
have United States. But let's say we want to ship
to another country, like maybe we want to ship to
Canada. So the shipping is gonna cost a little
more since I'm based in the United States.
And I'll do all of Canada. And here we're
gonna do a flat rate and it's going to be
this time $10 It's a little more because we have
to ship it a little further. And then I can go
back to shipping zone. And then you can see you
can also do local pickup if you want to add your
specific city or state and then you can choose
local pickup. Okay, let's look at some of these
options here. So you can choose whether you want
to hide the shipping cost until an address entered
or just depending on what you want to look like to
the customer. Now Shipping Classes allows you to
create different shipping costs for different
types of products. So maybe some products,
you'll be charging $5 for shipping, some
products, you'll be charging $10 for shipping,
I'm not going to show you this in this tutorial,
but you can add different Shipping Classes,
and then set your products to to go with that
shipping class. And then that product will, will
be charged that shipping rate. But let's go
to this next step here WooCommerce shipping.
And this is because we have the plugin installed,
we have the WooCommerce shipping plugin,
and it allows us to automatically print shipping
labels, and save a trip to the post office. So
you can choose some settings like where how are
you going to print the labels. And then if you
want to be able to purchase shipping labels
right through here. And so I'm just going
to leave this all as it is. Okay, now we're
going to learn about creating coupon codes,
it's actually pretty simple. So on the
WooCommerce area here, I'm gonna click on coupons.
It's telling us actually, on this new version, the
coupon management has moved. So let's remove the
legacy coupon menu. So we'll just be using the new
coupon menu, which is now in marketing coupons.
And all this, you can either click on
Create Your First coupon or just add coupon,
I'll click on Add coupon because it's the method
that you're going to be using the most. And
then we can just create the coupon code. And I'm
going to create the code rope robots are amazing.
This description is really just for you. And
I'll put robot coupon. And then there's a few
different types of coupons you can make, you can
make a percentage discount, so everything's going
to be 10% off a fixed cart discount. So you get $5
off your order, or a fixed product discount, which
is a discount that only applies to one specific
product. So what I'm going to do is create a
percentage discount. So we can put 10%. And then
you can choose whether you want to always allow
free shipping, or maybe maybe not. So the
coupon can include free shipping, or it cannot
and then you can choose when it expires.
So let's say it expires here a week later.
And then we can go over to usage restrictions. So
how much do they have to spend to be able to use
the coupon? So let's say they have to spend $20
To use the coupon. And what's the maximum number,
you may have no maximum. But maybe you don't want
them to be able to use a coupon on an order that's
over $500. And then you can choose whether the
coupon can be used with other coupons or not,
whether it should exclude sale items. And
then here is where you would choose if a
coupon applied only to a specific product. Or if a
product would be excluded from a coupon. You know,
there's some things that never go on sale like
have you ever seen a Nintendo Switch on sale?
Well, they would have that excluded. And then
you can apply the coupon only specific categories
exclude categories. And then if you only want
certain email addresses to be able to use it.
So only certain people can use the coupon, you can
put it here. And then we have the usage limit. So
how many times can this coupon be used? Well,
after 500 times a coupon can no longer be used
anymore. So how many here is how many items you
can use it for. So how many how full your cart
can be. And then how many times can each user
use a coupon, we'll just put one time, that
makes sense. Each user can only use the coupon
one time, obviously, someone could just create a
new account and use it again. But that limits it
somewhat. And I'm going to publish this coupon.
Okay, at this point, we're gonna test all this,
I'm gonna go to the store and purchase something
and use this coupon. So let me go to the store,
visit Store or visit site or visit store,
go to products, and x, I already have two things
in my cart from before, oh, an item which is no
longer available as you move from your cart. Well,
I'll remove this too. So I can do the whole thing
from the beginning. So let me go to the shop.
And I am going to get a hat. So I just add,
I just could click Add cart. And then here you
can add to the khaki to select the options first.
So I'm going to get a small shirt. That's
the color red. And I will add this to cart.
And so we have this options here where you can
pay without even going to the cart. Actually,
let's turn that off. Because we want someone to
actually have to go to the cart before they pay.
Okay, I'm on WooCommerce setting them on
payments. And I'm going to go down to where
it says Pay Pal. I'm going to manage that
and then I'm going to scroll down where it
says sync little product page. And then I'm
going to disable enable on single product.
So now it's not going to show up on the product
page will still show up on the cart though,
and I'm going to save changes. And one more
thing I'm going to do and we go back to the
Payments tab, and then I'm going to
go to the stripe payment settings.
And we are going to disable this Express
checkouts, so it's not going to show these Express
Checkout buttons. Okay, now let's go back to our
product page. Can I'll just refresh the cart page,
and you can see those buttons are gone. So I'll
add a medium of a small red shirt, add to cart.
Okay, now I'm going to view the cart. Okay,
these two cards, I thought he added a hat.
Let me go back and add a hat really quick.
And add to cart. Okay, now view the cart.
Okay, so now I have two shirts and the hat.
Now I'm going to a plot apply coupon. So
robots are amazing. Apply the coupon. Okay, now
you can see that we've got an A $9 discount. And
I can choose between Fred flat rate or
free shipping. Good, because remember,
we set free shipping, as long as the amount is
over $50. It's sewing that shipping to Michigan.
And then I'll proceed to checkout.
Okay, now I can put in some of my
information here. Then I'm going to put
in a demo credit card number from stripe.
And then he I don't think the numbers here
matter when I'm using the demo. Oh, yeah,
it could be in in test mode to test the
cart. So let me go back over to this menu.
I'm going to quickly go to Manage stripe, and then
enable test mode. Okay, let me save that. And then
I have to when I'm in test mode, you have to have
special test keys. So good edit account keys. Oh,
see, there's the live keys and there's the
test keys. So let me get the publishable key
and then the test secret key. And
then the test secret web hook.
So we're setting this up, just like before.
And I'm gonna add endpoint. And
then I just need to copy this ID
put it in here and save test keys. Okay, I'm
going to refresh the page, put in the billing
information. And then I'll put in this test credit
card information. And then place order. And thank
you your order has been received. Now let's
go look at our administrator email account.
So here's the administrator email account.
So we get an email when we receive an order,
and it's showing new order, you've received
an order from Beau Carnes and it has all the
information it has the shipping address. Now
let's go to our administrator dashboard. Now
if we go to orders here, we can see the order
it says order from Beau Carnes is processing.
So three items are rage fulfilled, I could create
the shipping labels in the product and go from
processing to completed. And then I'm going to
update that. And then in this Customers tab,
we can now see the customer would There's a new
customer. And then we can go to the Reports tab,
showing how much we've how much money we've
made. And then the Orders tab, we still have
that order in there. Finally, we are going to talk
about the emails that get sent to the customers.
So I'm gonna go to Settings, and then emails. So
here you can check the emails that get sent for
various reasons. So we already have the emails
go to the administrator email for New Order,
cancelled order failed order. But then an email
would get sent to customers for all these other
things such as a completed order processing
order. And if you click on Manage, you can
choose what the email is going to look like you
can enable or disable the email notification,
you can change the subject email heading
additional content, so you can choose what
email that you the customer is going to get. And
one thing to notice if I go back to the email tab
here, it has this message here. So in case if you
get this all set up and the email does not arrive
to the customer, you're gonna have to look at this
here to ensure your stores notifications arrive
in your and your customers inboxes we recommend
connecting your email address to your domain
and setting up a dedicated SMTP server. Something
doesn't seem to be saying correctly install the WP
mail logging plugin so It could just
work out of the box. But if it doesn't,
I would recommend installing this plugin. And
it's pretty straightforward. I'm not going to
show in this tutorial, but I will just take
you step by step into getting it working.
And then that will make it more likely
that your email will get to your customer.
Okay, we're almost done, there is one more loose
end I want to cover, which is this top bar here
where it has don't miss our holiday off for 20%
off, well, we probably don't want that because
it may not be a holiday. So I'm gonna go to
Customize. And then I'm gonna go to header.
And here's the top row. So if you remember,
there was the social icons on the right side,
and then we have the message on this side. So I'm
going to click here. And now here we can change
what message is in this top row here.
So maybe instead of the the holiday,
instead of talking about the holiday
offer, we can say check out our new hats.
And then you can actually make this a link
and you can link it to your hat page. So
I'm just gonna whoops, publish this.
Another thing I could do is just remove this
completely. So if I just exon socials, and exon
top row, or exon, this HTML thing, and I publish
it. Now if I go to my website, I'll just exit out
of this. Now we don't even have that row at the
top. So you may just not even want that top bar.
The store is complete. You now know how to set up
a fully functioning e commerce website. There are
a ton of settings and plugins that we didn't even
get to. So feel free to just explore the different
options and see how you can customize your store
even more. Good luck with selling your products.